madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition l'inauguration par jacques
chirac d'un centre de la mémoire
d'oradour sur glane ce village martyr ou
642 personnes hommes femmes enfants ont
été massacrées en juin 44 martine aubry
envisage de soutenir la loi sur
l'avortement pour l'instant un projet
qui prolongerait à 12 semaines le
recours légal ali b g les mineurs
pourraient être dispensés de
l'autorisation parentale le tour de
france avec l'abandon de christophe
bassons celui qui symbolise le courant
propre connu pour ses positions
tranchées à craquer et puis du tennis
avec ce match à suspense cinq heures
face à face sébastien grosjean gustavo
kuerten
finalement le français du cd au tie
break l'indispensable devoir de mémoire
pour que survivent dans les esprits une
fois les témoins disparus le martyre des
habitants d'oradour sur glane victimes
de la folie meurtrière nazis jacques
chirac ce matin une graisseux centre en
appelant à la vigilance contre la
barbarie
françois privat frédéric un chèque
émotion perceptible sur le visage du
président de la république au milieu des
ruines d'oradour-sur-glane durant plus
d'une heure
jacques chirac accompagné de catherine
trautmann ministre de la culture
écoute le récit de jean-marcel darthout
l'un des six rescapés du village martyre
où j'entendais beaucoup de la culasse
drôle de sensation qu'on ressent je
crois tout ça vise ceux censés
accompagner des enfants de l'école
d'oradour-sur-glane jacques chirac
inaugure le centre de la mémoire
exposition permanente construite autour
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
l'occasion pour lui de faire un
parallèle avec les massacres du kosovo
et de rappeler que pour la première fois
dans l'histoire grâce au tribunal pénal
international de la haye un chef d'état
en exercice en la personne de slobodan
milosevic vient d'être inculpé pour
crimes contre l'humanité
le 21e siècle
tirant toutes les leçons du passé sera
le siècle de l'éthique
je l'espère je le crois présence lourde
de symboles de catherine trautmann en
1953 l'aministie des malgré nous
alsaciens qui avaient participé au
massacre avait suscité l'indignation en
limousin il est évident que votre propre
marque présente l'alsace prouve aussi
que la réconciliation est fait et se
poursuivent ce qui est en train de se
construire entre entre strasbourg et et
oradour c'est sans doute une forme de
réconciliation sur le livre d'or
d'oradour-sur-glane ces quelques mots de
jacques chirac
les lieux de mémoire lieu de souffrance
et de violence nous confronte à l'avenir
autant qu'au passé c'était donc le 10
juin 44 642 personnes dont 2 400 enfants
et des femmes ont été massacrés puis
brûlé par les ss de la division das
reich plus d'un demi-siècle après sans
jamais que l'allemagne n'exprime un
regret ou demande pardon ce musée de la
mémoire après le parti de tout dire tout
raconté christophe devals embrasse
françois privat le centre de la mémoire
d'oradour sur glane l'aboutissement
d'une volonté depuis un demi-siècle
dénoncé devant l'histoire l'horreur
d'une guerre
ici tout est mort une ville incendiés
fusillé torturé au lendemain du massacre
le général de gaulle les sites de
conserver en l'état les ruines d'oradour
pour témoigner on tourne les premières
images qui fige dans l'histoire les
vestiges de la barbarie essais ils ont
rassemblé toute la population sur cette
place
d'un côté les hommes de l'autre les
femmes et les enfants les hommes ont les
emmener dans des granges et abattu et
puis on a mis le feu à leur cadart
les fans et les enfants on les a
rassemblés dans l'église et on les ia
mitrailler et brûlé vif
cinquante ans plus tard les ruines du
village sont toujours là mais des six
rescapés du massacre il n'en reste que
deux qui peuvent encore témoigner dont
jean d'arc son récit devant la grange où
il aurait dû périr permet de prendre
réellement conscience de l'horreur vécue
par les habitants
fauché par les rafales ss on a entendu
des voix qui parle et qui pleurait tes
plantes
c'est fou de stock à la volée les
plantes qu'ils pouvaient qu il pouvait
sortir ce que les gens aiment beaucoup
de gens était encore violent et là ils
ont mille fois aujourd'hui les
collégiens qui visitent les ruines
d'auradou reconnaissent les faits qui
s'y sont déroulés mais la guerre est
bien loin de leurs 13 ans ils ressentent
la cruauté qui a dévasté le village sans
réellement pouvoir comprendre ces morts
c'est ça veut rien dire ça fasse cdd
vous mord un peu c
on peut pas tellement exprimer ce qu'on
pense quoi ça fait peur dans les
couloirs du centre de la mémoire les
clés du village martyr le contexte
historique expliqué en détail des photos
les témoignages de ceux qui ont échappé
aux ss tous les éléments nécessaires
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé à
oradour-sur-glane les ruines sont
muettes sur ce qui leur est arrivé ce
qui nous a fait de venir en ruine et
l'oncle a avec le nouvel équipement du
sang de la mémoire
nous avons proposé un récit en préalable
à la visite du monument historique le
centre de la mémoire est désormais la
porte des ruines d'oradour mieux que de
ne pas oublier il permettra aux
générations à venir de comprendre
et pour sa part lionel jeu spa lors de
son voyage en pologne s'est rendu
aujourd'hui au camp d'extermination
d'auschwitz un geste privé un geste de
recueillement un peu plus tôt à varsovie
lionel jospin qui s'est dit prêt à aider
la pologne pour entrer rapidement dans
l'union européenne accompagnée de
plusieurs grands patrons
le premier ministre en a profité pour
vanter les mérites des entreprises
françaises alban nicosie jacques rivard
quelques instants de répit dans le
programme officiel quelques pas pour
lionel jospin et son épouse dans la
vieille ville de varsovie rasé par les
allemands en 45 reconstruite à
l'identique par les polonais de quoi
méditer sur les conséquences des guerres
mais officiellement il fut surtout
question d'avenir lors de cette visite
entretiens officiels à dominante
économique en présence de nombreux
ministres
aujourd'hui l'économie polonaise est en
pleine mutation à grands coups de
privatisation demain ce sera l'europe
des quinze sans donner de date précise
lionel jospin est venu soutenir cette
métamorphose au moment où l'opinion
s'interroge
j'ai dit à mon interlocuteur polonais
c'est un
vous montre scepticisme lui le
regretterai si c'est un mouvement de
réalisme mais cette visite fut également
parsemé de gestes plus personnel tout
d'abord parce que la pologne a vu naître
le grand père de son épouse sylviane qui
l'accompagnait de manière exceptionnelle
et surtout parce qu'en ce jour de
commémoration lionel jospin s'est rendu
à auschwitz cela n'avait pas de sens
pour moi de passer près de ce lieu de la
mémoire humaine sans m'y arrêter mais ce
sera un geste
privé de recueillement un hommage
personnel pas un geste politique sans
caméra sans interview dans ce lieu où
deux millions de personnes furent
exterminés la visite de lionel jospin
sera sobre et privés le lieu impose le
recueillement et l'entourage du premier
ministre a pris toutes les précautions
pour que personne ne songe à autre chose
au kosovo la difficile prise de
fonctions de bernard kouchner qui a
présidé le premier conseil transitoire
de la province en l'absence du parti
libre et y meurent hugo va qui
contestent la composition actuelle de ce
conseil après stinat nos envoyés
spéciaux agnès vahramian nathalie gallet
c'est la première contrariété de bernard
kouchner
il devait être installé aujourd'hui le
conseil consultatif du kosovo toutes les
tendances albanaise et serbe devait être
représenté mais voilà le parti d'ibrahim
rugova a refusé de venir
contestant les deux places accordées aux
leaders albanais de loups checa et à son
gouvernement autoproclamé des
divergences entre albanais une absence
de rue gauvin dont bernard kouchner se
serait bien passé il pense que le ldk
n'est pas suffisant que sa tendance
n'est pas suffisamment représentée
passer aux autres
nous connaissons ça dans tous les pays
il veut qu'ils ont rééquilibré nous
étions sur le point de le faire et il y
aura d'autres propositions qui j'espère
satisferont tout le monde bernard
kouchner est un inconnu pour les
habitants du kosovo pourtant il va
gouverner cette province il prendra des
décrets pour gérer les secteurs de la
santé de la vie scolaire pour remettre
sur pied les institutions le conseil
consultatif donnera son avis c'est la
première instance politique d'après
guerre les pops air blue checa tous ont
semble-t-il fait preuve de bonne volonté
au moins dans le discours mais que les
albanais en revanche soit déjà divisé le
présage rien de bon
mauvaise journée pour bernard kouchner
depuis quelques jours les nations unies
essayer de faire travailler ensemble
serbes et albanais à la mairie de
pristina mais la situation est vite
devenue intenable et l'expérience qui se
voulait modèle a capoté aujourd'hui vous
vous en souvenez des l'arrêt des
bombardements de l'alliance les
instances de l'onu avait mis en garde
les réfugiés contre les risques des
mines antipersonnel disséminées
abondamment à travers le kosovo
les forces françaises avait elle-même
été stoppés dans leur avancée le premier
jour or on est obligés aujourd'hui de
constater que ces mines laissées par les
troupes serbes sont en très petites
quantités mais qu'en revanche sur place
les difficultés viennent de toutes ces
bombes envoyées par les alliés et qui
n'ont pas explosé valérie fournier
frédéric basket
ils se relaient toutes les 20 minutes
car le geste doit être précis ces
légionnaires du 1er régiment étranger de
génie ont pour mission de repérer ici
les mines antipersonnel posées par les
forces yougoslaves autour de leurs
positions une fois dégagé le désamorçage
ne dure que quelques secondes
l'armée serbe est utilisé des mines anti
personnel pour assurer sa protection
ici les pma deux qui sont des mines qui
se déclenche quand on marche dessus qui
vous arrache le pied c'est un minage
uniquement de protection mais donc très
dense mais uniquement autour des
positions serbes et de nous checa car
contrairement à ce qu'avait annoncé
l'otan il ya moins de mines au kosovo
que prévu et les informations transmises
aux français étaient erronés
renseignements incomplets par fo info on
a été déçu non pas parce que ya pas la
quantité de mines
il y en a moins que ce qu'on pensait
mais déçu parce que le minage qu'on a
rencontrés ici la pollution en général
et plus difficile que ce qu'on a connu
ailleurs c'est que lors des frappes
aériennes
les forces américaines ou non seulement
larguer des missiles sur des sites de
communication comme ici mais également
des containers entiers de bombes de la
taille d'une grenade près de 10% n'ont
pas explosé comme prévu lors de l'impact
au sol
c'est ce que dit le constructeur mais
comme tout engin fabriqué par l'homme il
ya une marge d'incertitude
donc il reste un certain nombre de ces
munitions sur le terrain et en grand
nombre
des munitions de toutes sortes très
puissante qu'il faut retrouver sur des
centaines d'hectares pour les empêcher
de nuire et les points de chute de ces
explosifs n'ont pas été répertoriés par
l'otan qui les a pourtant marqué dans
l'actualité de ce vendredi cette
réflexion qui ne manquera pas de
susciter bien des commentaires et
sûrement des polémiques réflexions de
martine aubry qui envisage d'ici un an
d'allonger à 12 semaines le délai de
recours à l'avortement comme le font la
majorité des pays européens
pour l'instant cette mesure est à
l'étude elle impliquerait un
assouplissement de la loi veulent avec
pour philosophie garantir l'accès ali vg
française valais il y en a marre yossef
depuis la loi de 1975
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est un droit donc chaque femme doit
pouvoir bénéficier dans les meilleures
conditions
mais en raison du manque de structures
dans certains hôpitaux de la surcharge
de travail dans d'autres et parfois du
peu d'enthousiasmé des médecins les
femmes n'ont pas toujours accès à l'ivg
et g martine aubry envisage donc un
allongement du délai légal celui ci
passerait de 10 à 12 semaines comme dans
la plupart des pays européens pour les
centres de planification cette mesure
est importante
chaque année plus de 5000 femmes partent
avorter à l'étranger
il ya une inégalité des chances face à
lille et j'ai pour ces délais là puisque
c'est les femmes qui sont en situation
les plus précaires qui vont être amenés
à attendre ou a pas se rendre compte
rapidement de leur état de grossesse je
regrette que martine aubry demande aux
hôpitaux publics de remplir leur mission
est d'intégrer la pratique de l'ibg dans
tous les services de gynéco-obstétrique
de france mais pour la ministre
l'avortement doit rester un ultime
recours le plus important c'est la
prévention
la première action que je souhaite mener
pendant cette année c'est une action
très ample de communication pour faire
connaître les nouveaux moyens de
contraception notamment la pilule du
lendemain pour faire connaître toutes
les possibilités offertes par les moyens
de contraception à tous les publics et
notamment aux jeunes une grande campagne
d'information diffusés par la presse
écrite par la radio et la télévision est
prévu à partir d'octobre
j'en viens maintenant cette
manifestation des contribuables agacé
sinon révolté par le poids des impôts en
france ils se sont rassemblés près du
ministère des finances pour dire leur
colère
il ya une frontière cadre pour nous la
part de ses impôts et cotisations que
les français ont à payer une
manifestation qui se veut avant tout
symbolique symbolique comme ses costumes
de bagnères que ces contribuables en
colère ont revêtu voulait occuper
marchand enserrer pour des manifestants
qui se considère comme soumise aux
travaux forcés par le fisc
cela ressort des chiffres tout simple
qui est 54 % du produit intérieur brut
en france
perreault dépenses de l'état autrement
dit sur 100 francs gagné 54 france sert
aux dépens de l'état 54 % un chiffre à
nuancer voir à corriger car il prend en
compte par exemple le déficit budgétaire
de l'état qui n'est pas financée par nos
impôts
en fait le chiffre total des
prélèvements obligatoires impôts taxes
et cotisations est moindre 44 9% ce qui
place tout de même la france en tête du
peloton des pays occidentaux
en europe seuls les pays scandinaves
comme le danemark ou la suède dépasse le
montant de nos prélèvements la france
qui reste loin devant l'allemagne les
états unis ou encore le japon pays où
les prélèvements sont certes plus bas
mais où il faut souvent ajouter le coût
d'une assurance privée pour la retraite
et la santé quant à la répartition de
ces mêmes prélèvements en france sur les
44 9 % moins de la moitié 18 % vont au
budget de l'état notamment pour financer
l'éducation la défense ou encore les
aides à l'emploi et plus de la moitié
20,6 % reviennent en fait dans les
poches des français sous forme de
retraite d'allocations chômage ou de
prise en charge des problèmes de santé
des prélèvements qui devrait légèrement
baissé la france y est engagée auprès de
l'union européenne et ce dès 2002
dix ans après l'attentât contre le dc10
d'uta qui avait fait 170 morts les
autorités libyennes ont transféré en
france des fonds pour indemniser les
familles des victimes
en tout quelques 200 millions de francs
trois ans jour pour jour après le
meurtre de la jeune caroline dickinson
une piste prise très au sérieux par les
enquêteurs celle d'un homme ressemblant
tôt portrait robot présents dans la
région la veille du meurtre olivier sous
michel hiver au fond il n'y a pas
d'évènement majeur à défaut d'événement
majeur a annoncé les enquêteurs avaient
donc plutôt un message à faire passer
trois ans après le meurtre de caroline
dickinson l' enquête suit son cours
les gendarmes travaillent d'arrache-pied
le soixante années personne concrets de
recherche de l'appareil enquêteurs soit
en qualité de témoin donc faudrait
effectivement telle nous apporter des
éléments que nous avons pas actuellement
sur sur ce qui se passe exactement
certaines congères à l'époque des faits
autant dire les environnements ouverts
soit effectivement des individus qui
nous intéresse pour différentes raisons
et parmi ces individus intéressant il ya
en premier lieu ceux qu'on appelle la
piste d'entrain celle d'un homme aperçu
la veille du meurtre à quelques
kilomètres de pleine fougères
ce n'est pas une nouvelle piste plutôt
la confirmation d'investigation
anciennes pas question donc de lever le
pied comme le bruit en a couru la du
grain à moudre pour l'instant on ne
s'est pas fixé des délais ça ne se
situait pas comme ça on essaye de faire
en sorte d'arriver jusqu'au bout de
cette enquête
au bout de sept encaissés
l'interpellation l'arrestation de
l'auteur bref les enquêteurs affichent
leur optimisme une conviction partagée
par le père de caroline qui ce matin a
une nouvelle fois rencontré le juge van
ruymbeke ou de meurtres sont élucidés
bien des années après avoir été commis
on a les tests adn qui sont cruciaux on
n'a le portrait robot avec tout cela
l'aide de la population française
nous pourrons la trappe en angleterre la
sphère suscite toujours autant d'intérêt
de la part des médias et du public
deux diplomates de l'ambassade de grande
bretagne étaient d'ailleurs présents
aujourd'hui à rennes pour témoigner leur
soutien à la famille dickinson avec le
14 juillet la traditionnelle remise de
peine accordée par le président de la
république 4000 détenus ont bénéficié de
cette grâce collective
parce qu'elle dit c'est bon et frédéric
faure ont assisté à la libération de
l'un d'entre eux une matinée comme les
autres dans le couloir des entrées et
des sorties
quoique aujourd'hui le nombre de sorties
est un peu supérieur à la normale grâce
présidentielle oblige tous les détenus
le savent les derniers instants sont
parmi les plus durs
le matricule 268 1595 n'échappe pas à la
règle
jacques m'appelle et me laisser me
disent tu la fume dans un ruck et la
fuite et il n'a pas fermé l'oeil depuis
48 heures
sensi 23 ans a accepté notre présence de
bonne grâce à une condition ne pas dire
quels délits l'a envoyé pour 18 mois en
prison
c'est le passé dit il
le présent ce sont les effets confisqué
à l'incarcération qu'il récupère c'est
le soleil et le sourire de sa soeur
venus l'accueillir
35 et les habitudes reviennent après ce
que celle ci appelle un voyage au pays
de la punition punition méritée dit il
mais inadaptées statham personne tu
ressors de là avec beaucoup plus de
plantes est là beaucoup plus de plan
peut-être qu'ils ont pas au bout de deux
heures s'est habitué à vous les cinq
fronts à quelqu'un à chaque fois qu'on
est dedans tu apprends voulait fin
octobre lui prendre ce que tu veux je
suis pas le meilleur endroit pour calmer
quelques la main au moins at il
désormais une bonne raison de ne pas
récidiver sa fiancée la dja est natif
neuf mois n'est qu'en papin était à la
santé dit ce monsieur qui ce monsieur en
france un détenu sur trois purge sa
deuxième peine ou plus sensi jure de ne
plus mettre de mur entre son bonheur et
lui on encore en mémoire la catastrophe
du drac en décembre 95 au cours de
laquelle six enfants une accompagnatrice
s'était noyé dans la montée des eaux
hier près de bourg st maurice on a frôlé
le drame un groupe de quarante deux
adolescents et six accompagnateurs se
sont retrouvés coincés dans la vase
d'une rivière
alors que la centrale hydraulique
procédé à un lâcher d'eau le niveau du
cours d'eau s'est élevé de 30 cm forte
heureusement pas de victime
il ya un peu moins de deux heures le
lancement d'un vaisseau cargo vers mire
après ces querelles voir cette crise qui
empêchait au kazakhstan le départ de
tout lancement de fusée le progress a
finalement quitté la station de
baïkonour avec deux jours de retard
patrice pollet elle est donc enfin
partie cette fusée élite avec à son bord
le vaisseau progress au jour un vaisseau
de ravitaillement pour la station 1205
de nourriture
matériel nécessaire à la survie de
l'équipage jusqu'à la fin ceci marque la
reprise des lancements après le
différend entre les autorités russe et
kazakh les fusées qui s'écrase
les impayés de la location du site de
baïkonour depuis trois semaines les
casaques interdisait tout départ vers
l'espace 50 millions de dollars d'ici
novembre
soixante cinq autres millions sous forme
de marchandises pour permettre ce départ
est débloqué la situation
moscou a dû mettre la main à la poche si
tout se déroule bien dans 48 heures le
vaisseau progress s'arrimera la station
mais l'équipage avec à son bord le
français jean pierre haigneré pourra
envisager une fin de mission
pantagruélique une fête bien méritée
pour les derniers locataires de l'espace
qui ne laisseront en principe leur place
à personne puisque après leur départ
la station mir devraient être détruites
lors d'un plongeon spectaculaire vers la
terre il ya 30 ans presque jour pour
jour les astronautes américain
réussissait l'impensable marché sur la
lune si cette alunissage avait tourné au
drame
voici le projet qu'avait mise au point
la nasa et la maison blanche
l'histoire de cette oraison funèbre
heureusement sans effet eric lemasson
puisque tout a été dit sur ce soir d'été
69 ou le petit pas d'un homme devenait
un pas de géant pour tous les autres
trente ans après que 10 voici la
trouvaille d'un journal américain
raconte et non pas ce qui s'est passé et
ce qui se serait passé si tout ne
s'était pas bien passé
pour commencer ces images de triomphe
n'aurait bien sûr jamais existé surtout
un document d'époque confidentiel
intitulé dans le cas d'un désastre sur
la lune montre que si les deux
astronautes sont devenus des héros ils
auraient été des martyrs s'il n'y avait
jamais pu revenir
le plan prévoyait tout d'abord que le
président des états unis plutôt que de
converser avec eux comme il l'a fait
téléphone personnellement à leurs futurs
beurre puis la terre aurait coupé toute
liaison avec le vaisseau en détresse et
comme pour les décès en mer un pasteur
aurait recommandé les âmes daldry n'est
amstrong qu'au plus profond des
profondeurs
enfin richard nixon aurait prononcé ces
mots pathétique
le sort a voulu que les hommes qui sont
allés sur la lune pour l'explorer avec
un esprit de paix reposeront sur la lune
en paix
tout être humain qui lèvera les yeux
vers la lune dans les nuits à venir sera
qu'il existe un autre point du monde
faisant partie a jamais de l'humanité le
discours était prêt et c'est un autre
qui fut pire dans l'histoire telle
qu'elle s'est déroulée le module lunaire
est reparti vers la terre on ne refait
pas l'histoire
mais ce document démontre que les
américains fidèles à leur légende m
l'anticiper il avait décidément tout
prévu
en france parallèlement à l'armada du
siècle de roy la fête maritime du havre
vient de commencer mais à quelques
centaines de mètres de ces paquebots et
voiliers qui font rêver les touristes le
sentiment de tristesse sinon d'amertume
de ses ouvriers du dernier grand
chantier naval de la ville qui fermera
ses portes à l'automne reportage
stéphane haumant olivier robert les
beaux bolides autrefois sont les
éternels vedette des fêtes maritimes le
havre s'apprête à accueillir l'armada de
rouen et espère un million de visiteurs
mais à quelques encablures du port
le dernier chantier naval de la ville
sombre dans l'indifférence générale
il fermera en devant ces normes et chine
poule sera pas achevée la cathédrale de
toul est quasiment abandonné en cale
sèche après 100 ans d'histoire les
chantiers du havre sont victimes de la
concurrence et de leurs erreurs
stratégiques
le faste des années 80 est bien loin les
ouvriers sont amers que l'on fait les
bateaux sans eux
il observe le succès de la fête navire
est jalouse histoire d'amour trahi je
crois l'amour des les bateaux avant tout
j'ai l'amour de mon métier
l'amour des bateaux sont autre chose
nous on les construit on a un amour plus
profond déjà 2200 vous brillez on est
passé à vis sans fin août la moitié de
l'effectif sera à nouveau le sensible
sentiment étrange celui de devenir
soi-même un vestige l'armada la plupart
ont dit qu'il n'irait pas l'avoir et
plus finalement ils sont allés corner
sur sûr qu'on les aime ce tous ses
battants c
une forme de
de beauté d'élégance ne peut que les
aimer c'est sur la beauté l'élégance il
n'y a pas à lutter doivent recueillir on
préfère lego est notre quartier il les
rêves de voyages au travail sur des
sottises le tour de france avec cet
abandon dont on n'a pas fini de parler
le français christophe bass ans connu
pour ses prises de position tranchées et
qui symbolisait le coureur propre depuis
le début de la grande boucle 99
eh bien il a craqué dans la foulée des
médecins envisagent ou menacent de
rompre la loi du silence qui une
nouvelle fois j'aurai depuis le début
des épreuves florent gautreau philippe
deslandes ont pratiqué pourquoi d'une
fatigue et sûrement des prix mais sans
doute christophe bassons a décidé
d'abandonner ce tour qui ne voulait plus
de lui
trois copines
et puis et puis on verra plus tard voilà
ce matin au départ de saint galmier il
manque un vélo sur la voiture de la
française des jeux le numéro 152 mais
personne ne semble regretter le départ
de basson pas même ses coéquipiers
on est une équipe on est soudé il a pris
la place d'un coureur de ce qu'on rêve
tous ferme tour de france il a une il
agit subitement s'aperçoit que certaines
personnes étaient prévenus la veille au
soir alors que nous mêmes nous savions
pas
ce sont
des journalistes qui sont venus le
chercher à la sortie de l'hôtel nous a
pas dit au revoir
moi j'ai trouvé ça un peu un peu lâche
nous avions rencontré christophe bassons
il ya dix jours il était heureux de
courir son premier tour de france mais
il n'hésitait pas à évoquer les moeurs
du peloton est-ce qu'on peut gagner une
étape à l'eau claire en étant propre à 9
euros man après mois en costaud non ces
propos relayés dans une chronique
quotidienne dans le journal aujourd'hui
agacer sérieusement certains coureurs
je ne suis pas bien vu pour mes propos
concernant le dopage nombreux sont
pourtant les coureurs dégoûté par la
démonstration d'armstrong avait-il écrit
le 14 juillet armstrong en personne lui
avait conseillé de se taire basson était
devenu le mouton noir du peloton d'après
ses proches il aurait cédé à cette
pression le tout le monde ne lui
quasiment lui tournait le dos le peloton
d'un sont dans l'équipe monde donc
donc pour cent et d'un lien renoncer
basson a pourtant reçu aujourd'hui un
soutien indirect
les médecins de plusieurs équipes
françaises affirmant que le dopage sévit
toujours dans les équipes étrangères
l'abandon de christophe bassons jette un
voile sur ce tour 99 car si certaines
mauvaises habitudes ont disparu du
peloton
la loi du silence continue elle de
rainier et de faire des ravages
difficile dans ces conditions de croire
que le tour 99 puisse être celui du
renouveau
et puis la 12e étape du tour a été
remporté à saint flour par l'espagnol
david etxebarria l'amérique armstrong
conservé le maillot jaune
nathanaël de rincquesen alain poirier à
saint flour stéphane heulot était très
entouré le coureur de la française des
jeux n'a pas gagné la 12e étape les il a
fait un bond de 15 places au classement
général il est désormais sixième
c'est payé
c'était pas
et pas un objectif pendant 120 km
stéphane heulot et ses 11 compagnons
d'échappée vont rouler devant le peloton
leur avance frôle les 14 minutes il ya
dans ce groupe 7 français mais aucun
d'entre eux ne va s'imposer
l'espagnol et iberia à quelques
kilomètres de l'arrivée accélère
françois simon tente bien de le
rattraper
en vain dans l'ascension de saint flour
et de chez barria résiste et remporte
l'étape avec 25 secondes d'avancé sur le
champion de france et je me suis un peu
piégé lines armstrong est arrivé avec 12
minutes 35 de retard sur le vainqueur
il conserve bien sûr son maillot jaune
les il ya ce soir un deuxième français
classé dans les dix premiers au général
à moins de dix minutes de l'américain
tennis avec le match époustouflant qui a
opposé pendant près de cinq heures
sébastien grosjean à gustavo kuerten 5,7
et la fin au tie break le français avait
toutes les raisons d'y croire à la
victoire était au bout de la raquette à
pau christelle bertrand maryse richard
gustavo kuerten a gagné dans la douleur
le match s'est étiré en longueur 4e set
le brésilien a des crampes pourtant il a
commencé décontracté grosjean lui est un
peu tendue premier set 6 2 pour le
brésilien
ensuite le marathon commence la deuxième
manche se joue au tie break
grosjean égalise
troisième sexe retour à l'envoyeur
cette fois ci le tie break et pour que
règne quatrième manche même combat mais
le brésilien commence à souffrir les
muscles tétanisés
il n'arrive plus à courir pour gagner
grosjean n'a plus qu'à faire durer les
échanges
un autre trait break puis fait égaliser
à deux manches partout
or j'ai compati tout le monde a les
nerfs à vif cinquième set les deux
hommes sont à sept jeux partout grosjean
tient bon mais c'est que certaines dans
un sursaut qui s'impose au bout de plus
de quatre heures et demie de match
grosjean n'est pas passé loin de la
victoire guy forget elle lui dira
d'ailleurs qu'il a fait un grand match
le brésil mène pour l'instant à 0
kuerten le leader de l'équipe s'est
logiquement imposé maintenant c'est à
cédric pioline de limiter et puis dans
l'autre match qui oppose cédric pioline
à fernando mini génie le français mène
pour l'instant 2 sets à 0
à la veille du coup d'envoi des
dernières collections haute couture du
siècle l'arrivée sur le podium d'à
nouveau créateur peut être une nouvelle
coqueluche franck sorbier reportage
nicolas cornu langlois bernard connard
entrée en haute couture ne veut pas dire
que l'on s'éloigne des travaux manuels
au contraire pour franck sorbier qui
participe à toutes les étapes de la
création construit ses robes au plus
près du corps son dessin c'est continuer
ce qui lui a réussi en prêt-à-porter une
approche instinctive du vêtement 16
personnalités de la haute couture réuni
autour de cette table de la chambre
syndicale ont décidé de le parrainer ci
surviennent a été choisie plutôt que
d'autres
beaucoup de demandes c'est qu'il avait
justement un prêt-à-porter qui
préexistait sur lequel sa culture
s'appuyait vous comprendrez que
l'activité culture seuls 10 au lait
n'est plus suffisamment rentable les
prix sont trop élevés de la clientèle
aura il faut non seulement que la haute
couture demeure mais aussi qu'elle se
régénère avec la vigueur et la rigueur
de talents nouveaux la chambre syndicale
encourage donc les créateurs en leur
permettant de défilé mais aussi en leur
confiant des stagiaires qui maintiennent
les traditions de cet art c'est vrai que
moi je donne le meilleur de moi même je
me mets à la machine moi même mais il ya
aussi des gens qui travaillent et qui
ont la foi et je crois que c'est ce qui
est important de couture je crois qu'on
rentre en haute couture
un peu comme une vocation
la face cachée du vêtement est aussi
raffiné que l'endroit comble du luxe
pour environ 30 mille francs la robe on
a droit à un petit diamant dans le
secret des doublures ruban tulle
dentelle sculpte la silhouette création
poétique un peu sauvage
rendez vous mercredi au palais galliera
avec un défilé de 18 modèles séquence
émotion passion assuré les quinzièmes
francofolies de la rochelle avec cette
année une programmation de groupes plus
proche d'un public jeune comme le groupe
zebda mais aussi des artistes qui par
leur talent font souffler un vent de
folie sur cette manifestation éric
perrin christophe vignal il arrive en
bas tout directement de belgique où il
et n'hésitons pas à le dire une méga
star jean luc fonck l'âme du groupe
stella est optimiste par nature de la
dérision contre la triste réalité de la
vie je remplis ma tasse je remplis
même qui disent qu'elles débordent elle
dans cette chienne de vie
faut savoir tourner la page clame-t-il
ce son dernier album depuis dix ans
stella est le spécialiste de la chanson
calembours chassez le naturel il revient
au bungalow oui au départ que des gens
qui faisaient la musique s'amuser donc
j'ai fait un bon coup les gens s'amusent
a fait l'objet après j'ai compris que
des papillons mauvais mais comme on est
des marchés dans l'erreur on ne fait
qu'aller dedans mais porte conseil
la prochaine saison la fête toujours
mais cette fois au service des idées en
dix ans le groupe zebda n'a jamais
changé de cap rester intègre malgré le
succès pour dénoncer encore et toujours
les injustices sociales
une chanson sur taslima nasreen dédié
aux femmes algériennes la double peine
le racisme
zebda sait plus que quiconque faire d'un
concert un acte de contestation festive
sa gestion par une contradiction la
gestion de vouloir dire des choses
sérieuses en faisant et en faisant la
fête il ya quand même dans la fête une
universalité qui est forcément politique
tout à coup le train
oh
on ne peut rester indifférent aux
ambiances des cancers 2 et déjà
peut-être parce que s'ils expriment une
certaine idée de la fraternité
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle le principal titre
l'inauguration par jacques chirac d'un
centre de la mémoire d'oradour sur glane
ce village martyr ou 642 personnes ont
été massacrées en juin 44
dans un instant la météo présentée par
patrice drevet est suivi du point route
de valérie maurice à 20h50 votre série
urgences
00h10 le dernier journal présenté par
laurence ostolaza j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver demain 13h je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée si on peut
aujourd'hui
tous
à